这天工作两个小时就能财务自由
这个不是为言送听
我过去10年差不多就是这么做的
所以我也不准备打操宝
就是想到什么说什么
更加分享我这两个小时的都随上
你们讲就会这样
所以你我也不考虑你爱白天
你自己决定吧
因为它可能对你是有用的
我不准备在面包上
啥一堆话学要计
分辨的相似
我觉得那个很不了
其实底层的东西很简单
就是选择比努力重要
你是不是觉得你知道
你不知道
你相信我啊
我后门告诉你
为什么你不知道
我前两天跟大家分享过
说其实
讲过效能和效率的事
就是你每天
就大部分是个罗斯
你觉得你的效率很高
我刚刚其实工作一天
我就打了一个罗斯
而且我发现那49罗斯
根本就不需要
这就是效能
其实就是我们说的
这个选择比努力重要
对吧
好
我后面会告诉你
为什么这个这么会事
然后来讲我的
每天的生活是什么
一般早上我会送姑娘上学
然后送到学校的话
大家大概是8.158.24左右
然后我就会在他们学校
外边的操场上
路边三部一个时候我有高水洋
他在三部
另外一个我觉得这是个很好的方法
干嘛呢
三部的时候会想一件事
就今天我要干什么
他其实不是零食想
是我有一个常常会的目标
然后我有个短期的目标
然后今天要干什么
想得也差不多太多了
也三部也差不多就回来了
所以第一个
我老的大概我今天要干什么
然后回来以后的话
就泡泡茶
放在音乐
然后准备一下
然后实际着中左右
很多老会都知道
多看我都会看我直播
然后我会把直播打开
然后工作三十分钟
注意啊
这个不是凡节中
很多人在那边这种凡节中
你说的凡节中也没问题
谁想真实的原因是什么呢
因为我有我这个四王王司令
你看我这身上全是全是问题
高学呀
二十多听不见
听实
是王王司令
对了
就是要保养身体吧
对吧
所以
想得哪了
就是
这三十分钟我干嘛
我告诉你
这三十分钟我只干一件事
就是我要干什么
中间可能会有哪些关键干净
认真真净净净一个关键干净
比如说这个关键干净
就是选择大育努力
我听过吗
我听过
但是我不认为
我知道我看明白了
你就那条理解
我是真的会画大各的事情
查各种各样的书记
AI
然后去理解
是出深刻的理解
在他三十分钟里面去理解
什么叫做选择大育努力
找各种案例
找背后的逻辑
找背后的原因
我认为我一定要能搞这件事情
所以我每天我其实要花很多事件
这里也准关键干净的
比如说
你想这种魔星4A
对吧
这每天都会有这样一个
一个4A 对吧
或者是什么
或者是
心制 心制社会
对吧
最终
我就不打了
就是每天都会有这样的
一些关键干净
理解一个深刻的关键干净
三十分钟
好
然后呢
跟老伙你们聊五分钟
如果直播的时候
那也三十分钟什么时候不干呢
就是关键这个事
然后聊五分钟
然后第二个
注意第二三十分钟
我干净什么时候呢
当我理解了这个深刻的干净之后
我在想
他怎么能和我的生活
和我的工作和我的系统年纪
对吧
比如说
他刚才说
选择打了一努力
那我就会想
我的工作中
哪一些事
其实是投入
尝证明不高的
生活中
哪一些事
其实是在浪费时间的
我要把它的看掉
就真的就会这么做呀
然后哪一些事
是可以把他挂到系统而已的
我的系统应该怎么去做的
注意不一定会做
这个是只想
他怎么和我的
和我的生活工作年纪的起来
出一个计划
就是就是一个清单
我要干什么干什么
好
大概有这么多事
就是选择什么
和生活工作年代快
做个计划而已
休息五分钟
然后第三年事
就把这个事
若是到我的系统中
若是到我的工作中
把它变成我的计划
把它放到我的系统中的一部分
我给大家久了一次
我现在有些时候
我会和我的AI去讨论一些事
讨论这个事
偏那时候
因为我在系统里面
你告诉我了
我的人生方向是什么
我短期的你不要是什么
然后讨论这个事
偏那时候这个系统会告诉我
我已经给他设定好了
会告诉我
你做这个事好像和你的系统会
你确定你要做的事情吗
我必须输输谷谷
我为什么要做电视频
原因是什么
我才能解掉一下做
这个系统
讨讨讨论就告诉我
你你这个事你不能干
你干错了
你听对吧
听是告诉我
所以基本上就这样
有些时候能干完有时候干不完
但是不管怎么样
我那个时候已经可以成长一张
只是卡片了
对吧
什么叫做选择答应努力
他是为什么
是什么
我的生活中可以怎么改
然后我是怎么做的
一二三十五
把他列出来
也有的时候
可能没做完
没事放点练的那
就是我要去做
然后呢
上一个时间干嘛
就和睡片时间吧
有时候接孩子的时候
等孩子
还因为你要提前到学校
你不能等孩子下课了
你应该去对你提前去
基本上就会稍稍稍稍稍疾
现在有AI了吗
对吧
你就可以用手机给
什么发展面量
中间抽控的时间
上个卫生间的时候
抽控的时间干一个
那很难说
你这个好像也没有两个
也不是两个小时
对吧
两个三个三三三
三十分钟嘛
就是一万一要什么
对吧
早上三目
中间
二十点可能三个多少时
四个小时
把单身
真正有效的工作时间
就是两个小时
我的家说为什么
我说了两个小时
他能够时间才会自由
我来解释一下
首先第一件事情
你们注意到了吗
就是
我说哪儿子
我用哪儿子的时间
可能会更多一些
首先第一件事情
就是我要深刻的理解
一个观念感觉
我在升级我的操作系统
你们注意到了
我在升级我的哪儿子
我在升级我的操作系统
所以这个时候
我的操作系统
我的哪儿子
可以去解决一些更深的问题
就像哪里装了一堆
最重
这种
四个模型
脑子里装了一堆四个模型
就像差点忙合说的
好吧
你有一个C空架
C空架里面挂了很多的C模型
然后这种C模型
在生活中不断的多的几天
然后你就会有一套空架
你就空架会解决一些更深的问题
这第一个
第二个的话
每天一块
你只有一块片
有时候是一个有数量
然后呢
这些卡片
几带一块
就像这个高一样
它就会主成一个更大的高的
你就会有一个更强大的工具箱
去解决更大的问题
前面是更深的问题
前面是更大的问题
更大的
第三的话
其实每天你不需要去工作
那么长时间
你每天可能工作
两个要是
可能随便耳加上三四个要是
对吧
这样
你就会通出更多的时间的
你是很聪输的
你是很有人有余的
你不会那么抱着我
你才好多人看我
每天在
下个
让它特别好
这个是
就是因为你会很封松
对吧
赶紧越来是你挂了
对
你是健康的发展
为什么你能做得更好
但可能说
这方法很好
但我不是因为
我每天要工作八票时
每天要有工作十个小时
那怎么办呢
我告诉你
你也可以做
三件事
第一件事
你每天
抽出三十个钟
这点错误来吧
就是早上
你要不着急点
也不着晚上
稍微要把睡一点
对吧
要不然你能不能
不耍短视频哪是吧
小达的留意
少吃点半
行不行啊
这什么路上
行不行
从我们再说
做什么抽出三十个钟
这你要做不到的
那我也没吃了
对吧
第一个
抽出三十个钟
这三十个钟
认认真真理解一个
关键赶紧
认认认真真理解一个
赶紧要不要判输
或者看的视频
这都是我懂得多个屁员你懂了
你懂了你的生活
还能这样的吗
对吧
所以好好地理解
背好的东西
看看他怎么应用在我的生活中
然后若是
可能今天只是看了
明天去和我的生活的那一块
后天晚上
对吧
我一天晚上的眼神
那你能不能三天
能不能一个礼拜呢
是不是
第三
第二个有的吧
第三个的话
你会发现你不是一天要打
一百个楼死了
对吧
你每天还要你会发现
只是生意一个关键的东西
让你的楼死每天
能有一点点生计
所以这个事的本质
什么这个不是本质
不是每天
我花十个小时去打楼死
而是每天花两个小时
去称称我们的操作系统
然后就做那个最关键的
如果是
然后顺利成长的
关键就好了